I believe you're a fan of Walter White
breaking them yeah you would think so
right yeah most of us are um were you
thinking of his character uh when you
were preparing to play no no I mean I
love Breaking Bad I was a huge fan and
and the definitely similarities about
you know regular guy just suddenly
turning to crime and I think there is a
difference though um Walter White made a
choice and in many ways well of course
Jacob makes make choices but they're
pretty much forced on it so I think
there is a that's quite a significant
difference let's pretend we have a time
machine and we'll go back to 1993 94 ok
Night Watch yes so say we wrapped on
film did you have a plan B just in case
this crazy acting thing oh no never had
a plan B for some reason I'm very stupid
I've always had I guess a very young and
unrealistic belief that it would work
out um but it did for some reason yeah
do you think that there was a strategy
to it aside from Halloween oh yes the
Stratton no I I wanted to I have a dream
of you know I wanted to even when I did
not watch had already been accepted to a
theater school in England so I was
always just finished four years of
training in demo'd then I was going to
do this movie and then go to Bristol Old
Vic you know where Daniel day-lewis had
gone it was very exciting I went there
for two weeks and then I ran away and
but I always wanted to act and I wanted
to travel the world if I could and so
that was the plan
then I moved to London and then slowly
but surely I started getting work no if
you're in a similar boat soon Game of
Thrones if it ends does it put new
pressure on you to find something else
or you feel it's almost like freedom
because well it's not like I happened I
mean I've been doing this 25 years I've
been working every year I haven't had
any downtime I've never I mean
to worry that you're in something that's
successful that's going to hurt you I
mean that's the least of my worries it's
usually the other way around did you do
something and you are that no one will
want to see it and you have been working
and every year of doing Game of Thrones
and I hope that if I choose that I'll
continue to be working
do you like the unknown the freedom of
possibility yeah I mean I that's that's
the I guess that's the nature of being
an actor unless you were like in a
theater where you but usually most
actors we all freelance and it's not so
much a question of liking it it's just
the way it is it's the condition hi
thank you
you